matteo ghisalberti rédacteur en chef de
putsch immédiat et bonsoir matteo
ghisalberti merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur rtl france alors on vient de le
dire les sénateurs se sont réunis
aujourd'hui pour voter la fin de
l'immunité parlementaire pour matteo
salvini première question tout
simplement quelles vont être les
conséquences de cette décision que
monsieur solvénie serra soumis à un
procès mais je pense aussi qu'il y aura
beaucoup de conséquences politiques
ado niveau déjà au niveau du
gouvernement parce que il ne faut pas
oublier que le gouvernement à partir du
président du conseil des ministres
risque d'être de devenir l'objet des
procédures judiciaires pour la gestion
de la crise sanitaire liée aux coûts
vite
le président du conseil des ministres a
déjà été entendu par des juges les juges
de la ville de bergame où il y a eu le
le pic de cette épidémie menée en chine
et donc on pourrait se retrouver d'ici
quelques mois dans des situations
similaires donc ça serait difficile de
justifier une non autorisation une onde
l'élever et de l'immunité parlementaire
pour des membres du gouvernement actuel
alors que pour matteo salvini c'est lé
cas
et puis il ne faut pas oublier les
effets dans l'opinion publique il y a
quelques semaines on avait appris
à travers notamment un quotidien celui
qui s'appelle la vérité des des échanges
entre des magistrats qu'à l'époque des
ces débarquements qui avait été un péché
par le ministre matteo salvini avait dit
mathieu s'aligner à raison mais nous
devons le juger quand même donc on voit
qu'il y a quand même une dimension
politique une dimension de lutte
politique contre matteo salvini on peut
penser ce qu'on veut de lui
mais c'est assez schizophrène cette
situation où on voit un parlement un
sénat qui donne une autorisation pour
conduire ouvrir un procès contre l'un
des ses membres et en revanche on voit
que la magistrature n'est pas toujours
indépendante ou en tout cas cette
position d'équidistance vis-à-vis des
des raisons politiques
alors matteo salvini va être poursuivi
un tour cycliste séquestration de
personne aggravée est-ce que les
sanctions peuvent être lourdes contre
lui théoriquement oui mais il ne faut
pas oublier qu'il était le ministre de
l'intérieur donc le ministère de
l'intérieur dans la plupart des pays du
monde est celui qui doit garantir la
sécurité du sur le territoire national
et c'est ce qu'il était en train de
faire d'ailleurs il ne faut pas oublier
non plus que la décision avait été aussi
partagé par une partie du gouvernement
de l'étang que qui était le gouvernement
de compter 1
donc c'est un peu je répète une
situation peu schizophrène parce que
il ya clairement un jugement politique
qui voudrait être utilisé pour pour
abattre année un ennemi qui
potentiellement pourrait remporter des
élections et montre aussi la faiblesse
de l'actuel gouvernement qui détendent
d'une majorité très très effiloché
surtout au sénat alors on l'a vu un le
flux migratoire continue d'augmenter en
italie même en cette période de crise
sanitaire comment comment peut on
expliquer tout simplement parce que il y
a les ong qui elle continue à vouloir
aider les conduire les situations plus
extrêmes
bien sûr il ya effectivement une
exigence de secours vis-à-vis d'eux des
milliers des personnes qui se trouvent
dans le nord de l'afrique est au même
moment on sait qu'il y a aussi des
problèmes on sait pas où s'arrête la
contenir les bonnes intentions et où
arrive où commence en réalité les
trafics d'êtres humains et des passeurs
donc c'est très compliqué de comprendre
si on est en train de faire du bien ou
en train de faire du mal là il ya
quelques instants je vais passer des
images qui ont fait débat train en
italie parce qu'on a vu des personnes
qui arrivent et se présentant comme des
réfugiés mais qui arrivait avec un
caniche donc comme si c'était un peu de
touristes on voit que d'ailleurs il y a
quelques semaines quand il y avait des
soupçons de plus important mais qui sont
en temps de recommencer
sur l'état de santé en ce qui concerne
le coc vide des certains migrants
le gouvernement actuel avait fait
exactement ce que ça finit à fait bien
non donc il avait fait arriver sur la
côte les navires mais il avait transféré
immédiatement les migrants sur un bateau
affrété pour être une sorte de deux
zones de conduire des des contrôles d
état sanitaire des migrants
donc on voit que le problème de la dé
l'immigration clandestine va devenir de
plus en plus importants et les italiens
auront du mal à comprendre pourquoi ils
ont dû rester confiné pendant des mois
et pourquoi elle doit porter des masques
un peu partout alors que des personnes
qui ne respectent pas ces règles et qui
sont potentiellement aussi malades
peuvent plus circuler sans problème sur
le territoire national merci beaucoup ma
théorie d'alberti d'avoir été avec nous
ce soir sur rtl france rappelle que vous
êtes rédacteur en chef de putsch médias
merci beaucoup